President Biden today confirming that
Hamas has killed at least 11 Americans
as the terrorists threaten to execute
hostages one by one it's the latest
terrifying twist as Israel goes to war
against Hamas after the terror group
launched the deadliest single day attack
on the Jewish people since the Holocaust
right now Israeli Defense Forces are
preparing for an imminent ground
invasion of Gaza after bombarding them
all day with air strikes the Carnage
starting and a music festival over the
weekend so far at least 1,000 men women
and children have been brutally murdered
by Hamas and as mentioned hundreds have
been taken captive including this
gut-wrenching scene of a woman being
taken hostage prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu assuring his Nation a couple
of hours
ago we didn't want this war it was
forced Upon Us in the most brutal and
Savage way Hamas will understand that by
attacking us they've made a mistake of
historic proportions Hamas terrorists
bound burned and executed children they
are
savages Hamas is Isis and now everyone
is asking the $6 billion question did
the Biden administ ation help fuel the
terror in Israel The Wall Street Journal
reporting that Iran was directly
involved and worked with the terror
group Hamas for weeks to plan the
attacks this comes directly after the US
unfroze $6 billion in Iranian funds but
the White House insists the money isn't
going to Terror money is fungible so
Iran may have known this money is coming
and used other funds Iran has
unfortunately always used and focused
its funds on supporting terrorism on
supporting groups like uh like Hamas uh
and it's done that when there have been
sanctions it's done that that money can
be refren at any time doesn't it seem
like a good time to do that we won't
hesitate to make that decision none of
that money has been allocated or gone
into Iran yet uh they don't get access
to it and it is only for humanitarian
purposes all right judge I you know
obviously I was away last week um was
able to see the five on Friday and then
I think okay so I'm geing up Monday I
know what we're going to talk about
internal politics here all these things
and only takes something like this to
completely Focus your mind on what's
really important yeah not only what's
really important but also what is really
dangerous the truth is that a ma the
magnitude of this cannot be understated
I mean without even getting into the
history of why or how the Jewish people
have there has been an attempt to
exterminate them from the beginning of
time to Hitler to now we have a group
that is doing this not for a military
reason but to destroy and kill Jews and
we have to recognize that that's what
this is about it's not about territory
it's about killing and erasing the
Jewish population now the failure of us
and Israeli intelligence has changed the
nature of terrorism and for the first
time in our country and I think for the
first time in history
we're seeing terrorists operating in a
way that is tactical that is uh
organized and is orchestrated and it's
no surprise that Iran was behind it
because when you think about it these
tactical movements they went after the
military I mean they even seized the
tank uh with with isra with an Israeli
commander and crew in the tank that's
like unheard of in the military they
went after Children and Families house
to house they put a missile try put a
missile into Tel Aviv from Gaza and um
they they are now they have now taken
hostages so the fact that we didn't know
this was coming the fact that even you
know I think Jake Sullivan said not that
long ago gee it's been so quiet that as
a secretary of uh not a secretary of
state is his position of National
Security he said he said we haven't seen
something like this in decades it's
almost the Comm before could I play that
judge and then have you continue we have
this if you could pull this up call for
number one here is Jake
Sullivan middle east region is quieter
today than it has been in two decades
now challenges remain Iran's nuclear
weapons program the tensions between
Israelis and Palestinians but the amount
of time that I have to spend on crisis
and conflict in the Middle East today
compared to any of my predecessors going
back to 9/11 is significantly reduced
you seei Valley one of the questions was
the farther we get from September 11th
the closer we are to September 10th yes
nobody wanted to see this but it does
remind you that you have to be right
100% of the time and they only have to
be right once it is the Cal before the
storm that he did not recognize and that
the lack of knowledge that both the
United States and Israel had is even
more concerning because if you can't
figure out how you were blindsided then
you cannot figure out how you're going
to win this war and with the enormous
power of Iran behind this and now we
know not from our government but from
the Wall Street Journal that Iran gave
the okay in Beirut which is run by
isbella let's make no mistake about that
on Monday for this attack on Saturday it
is clear that Hamas was behind this and
Hamas is orchestrated and I just want to
say h a couple more things Israel
abandoned Gaza in 2005 Hamas took over
in 2007 Israel allows 20,000 people a
day to come from uh uh the Gaza Strip to
Israel to make a living and let them go
back Israel has given Gaza to the
Palestinians and this is what they get
in exchange and going forward I think
that there's got to be a no equivocation
about how Israel will fight back against
this barbaric Invasion Charlie feel free
to comment on whatever you want but I
did want to ask this how was it that
the intelligence Community misses it but
the Wall Street Journal in 24 hours has
four sources on the record saying that
yes Iran was planning this all along the
most confusing part about all of this
from from the beginning was how badly
not just the United States missed this
but how badly Israel missed this I'm
used to the American government being
totally incompetent but I but you don't
think of the Israeli government as being
incompetent especially when it comes to
their security they usually take this
very seriously and so it's sort of a
it's a really sort of a bizarre
situation to find ourselves in and it
makes you wonder if we still don't know
all the factors that are at play and
what exactly is is going on here um I do
think that uh I think it's you know
talking about 911 one of the things
that's most alarming to me about it is
when you you know 9911 was a bunch of
half-trained
Pilots with box cutters and they brought
the world to a halt and then here you
have these lunatics and paragliders and
machine guns who managed to pull off the
biggest attack on Israel in 50 years
it's the Simplicity of it and the
rudiment and obviously it was very
sophisticated you know the planning you
know Israel uh Iran has you know their
fingerprints all over this and and the
money that went to them um and of course
you know why why did they you know this
is 50 years and one day after the start
of the yam kapor War why did they wait
one day because they wanted to kill Jews
on their Sabbath that's how they these
people operate which I think tells you
about all you you need to know about
these people you know if you are Israel
and you were living in that part of the
world and you value human life you're at
a tremendous disadvantage when you're
dealing with people who have no value
for for human life Jessica any I just
want to open the floor to you because
I'm imagine you probably have friends
and that are there and reeling a lot of
friends um one of my best friends um her
family now lives in London but a bunch
of them are still in Israel they're in
Tel Aviv they're safe thankfully um but
it has been non-stop tears that her
mother says it is impossible to do
anything but to cry um when you look at
what's gone on and all that they've
worked for I mean they have spent
decades creating a a peaceful
coexistence or what they want to be a
peaceful coexistence with the
Palestinians as the judge said um
privileg is coming in and out there's a
tremendous Arab population within Israel
that are treated just as Israeli
citizens given things like Social
Security I mean if there's a suit an
Arab suicide bomber the Israeli
government will still take care of their
family after that person detonates I
mean that's the level of generosity that
the Israeli people continue to show even
when the other side wants them wiped off
the face of the planet and is very clear
about that I think um to the judge in
Charlie's point the int intelligence
failure is not only abysmal but one of
the more confusing things I've ever seen
mosad is the best yeah I mean
I say that with Incredible pride in the
American intelligence forces and they
would even tell you if you want
something done mosad is the one that
knows and it raises the questions there
was a report that came out earlier today
and the Israeli Ambassador was on with
Neil Kabuto Neil asked him about it that
Egypt had reached out about 10 days ago
and said we're hearing Rumblings about
something coming and that they were
surprised by how disinterested Netanyahu
was in that now again the Ambassador
pushed back on that it is an interesting
thread to follow the second piece of
this is that Netanyahu has spent the
last Almost year 3/4 of a year fighting
back internal protests within the
country because of how he wanted to
overhaul the the judicial system it's a
huge problem um would completely Chang
the way the government works in Israel
everyday Israelis is hugely against it
and he has had to move IDF soldiers
around he has to put all his attention
there attention there has he taken his
eye off the ball M The Wall Street
Journal reporting obviously hugely
interesting waiting for the US and
Israel to confirm right they have
they've said we haven't been able to get
there now I don't see any reason why
they wouldn't tell us that it's not like
we don't know that Iran is a huge
sponsor of terrorism and that we don't
know that Vladimir Putin is the one
who's behind the cash flow right going
straight to Hamas but I should say
something about this $6 billion do so
the $6 billion doar is not American
taxpayer money that is false it is from
oil sales Iranian oil sales to South
Korea so it was being held in Juan and
it has been moved now to a qari bank
account which is being overseen by US
Treasury officials and the qari
government not $1 doar has moved out of
that account and it's supposed to be for
humanitarian groups and as John Kirby
said the funds can be refrozen at any
moment but when you see and there's so
much misinformation now on Twitter I put
that on Elon Musk but you see like Eric
Trump for instance posted a video of
rockets saying this is what happens when
you give them $6 billion Musk
Yes actually so the rockets that he put
up there was actually from Aleppo in
Syria from 2020 he took an old image and
said this is what you get so fix the
internet but also don't blame the
American government for this these are
not American dollars and none of it was
spent uh Greg well I mean the obvious
answer is nothing is ever going to be
direct because money is fungible right
you give me a hundred bucks to buy a
coat and say it's only for a coat that
means the hundred bucks in my bank
account that was originally for that
coat I can spend on knives and a rope
that's how it works um peaceful
coexistence is really easy to undermine
with a mind virus this isn't about
territory it's about an ideology and
it's not about just Israel it's about us
taking our eye off the ball we're going
to talk about this topic for an hour and
viewers May wonder why because we have
our own challenges here but it's the
same challenge the difference in Israel
it was a surprise explosion of atrocity
but ours has been a slow boil coming for
years it's not Hamas versus Israel but
we're on a road to Damascus real soon
have you seen the celebrations outside
it's absolutely amazing how professional
those signs are and to do that in just
24 hours it's almost as though this was
planned and that every celebration
around the world knew that this was
coming so you have an explosion of
violence and you have a slow boil here
but the origin of heat is the same
identity politics which fu F separatist
conflict which then the
Brainwashed embrac the oppressor versus
oppressed ideology the leaders are safe
right because they're not coming after
them but you're not safe the filter
allows one group of people to attack
another and God forbid you defend
yourself because then what they do is
they yell immediate ceasefire it's a
free punch on MSNBC people like Ali veli
and others said the Israel occupation
could be blamed for these attacks so
what does that remind you of when MSNBC
blamed the riots and violence post Floyd
on white nationalist mobs it's the same
mindset people here are defending the
atrocities even cheering it using the
phrases both sides and pleading for us
to use Nuance when we're talking about
abductions of girls and rapes and
mutilations this is not just specific to
Israel this is a global mind virus and
we our eyes are off the ball when it
comes to this so This oppression filter
leads to this free punch phase that's
when the oppressed can attack you
without consequence hence immediately
after the attack we are told by the
Progressive Progressive faction we
mustn't fight back they can hit you you
can hit them what do you see that in
America riots were a free punch
eliminating bail was a free punch Smash
and grab is a free punch Killers
murdering an activist and then the
friends of the activist defending the
murderer free punch blame the system
tear down statues free punch burning
cour houses free punch destroying
businesses that's a free punch you see
this thing is endemic everywhere so the
excuses for Hamas follow the same
excuses we have for criminality here
it's the fault of those targeted and you
can take a cowardly punch against
anybody because you can't there's a 40%
increase in violence against women in
New York City alone but AOC prefers to
focus on an anti-racist oyster Reef
in Israel the punch is Relentless
they're used to it it's still awful this
weekend was an all- at once punch but
for us it's a slow boil and it's coming
we have to be aware of that because
we're seeing the same mentality on the
streets right now so don't think it's
far away it's here it's on our streets
all right more breaking news as Israel
gears up for an imminent ground assault
of Gaza Trey yingst is on the ground
there he will join us for a live report
so you'll get that next hi everyone I'm
Brian kilme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now